حسنًا ، يصفها المسؤولون الروس بأنها
لحظة سبوتنيك قفزة تكنولوجية
مثل الإطلاق غير المتوقع
للفضاء
لأول قمر صناعي في الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي
ويقول المسؤولون الأيرلنديون
إن لقاح فيروس كورونا يتم
إطلاقه في
الوباء العالمي لتسليط الضوء على
الإنجاز العلمي الروسي وهذا هو
أوضح مؤشر لدينا حتى الآن عن
موعد الموافقة على استخدام اللقاح الروسي لاستخدامه ،
وقال المسؤولون الروس لشبكة CNN
إنهم يعملون نحو تاريخ
العاشر من أغسطس ،
وربما حتى قبل ذلك بشكل
سريع للغاية وفقًا للمسؤولين الروس
لأن التكنولوجيا التي يستخدمونها
باستخدامهم بنجاح في الماضي على
لقاحات أخرى
ولكن أيضًا لا يمكن إنكاره لأن التجارب البشرية
ستظل غير مكتملة عندما
تتم الموافقة على اللقاح ، أخبر المسؤولون الروس CNN
أن المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب البشرية ستُجرى
فقط بالتوازي مع تطعيم
العاملين الطبيين في الخطوط الأمامية محفوف بالمخاطر
بالطبع ولكن
بالنظر إلى مشكلة الفيروس التاجي الحادة في
روسيا  وهو رابع أكبر
عدد من الإصابات في العالم ،
فمن الواضح أن هناك خطرًا من أن
السلطات هنا على استعداد
لاتخاذها الآن ، وهناك بالطبع
شكوك هائلة حول العالم
حول فعالية وسلامة هذا
اللقاح الروسي يقول منتقدو روسيا إن روسيا
تدفع باتجاه ذلك  يأتي وسط
ضغوط سياسية من الكرملين
ومزاعم بأن الجواسيس الروس
اخترقوا مختبراتنا الكندية والبريطانية بحثًا عن
أسرار لقاح ،
ولم يتم إصدار أي بيانات اختبار من
قبل روسيا حتى الآن ،
لكن المسؤولين الروس يخبرونني الآن أن
هذه البيانات ستكون متاحة
للنشر والأقران  مراجعة أوائل الشهر المقبل والتي
ستجذب بلا شك قدرًا كبيرًا من
التدقيق الدولي فرصة ماثيو سي إن إن
موسكو